j'accueille maintenant bien abouti
jérôme busi bonsoir pour toi alors avec
laurent baffie et vous ce soir on a les
deux plus gros succès de la scène
parisienne en ce moment sacha black lui
donc je commande un peignoir sur mesure
entre prochaine il ya en peignoir a très
bien avec des pantoufles à l'arrêt donc
vous ces joyeuses pâques de jean poiret
mis en scène par bernard murat avec
caroline sihol barbara schulz monit
tarbès vous et le théâtre c'est le
théâtre des variétés boulevard
montmartre exactement le même boulevard
que laurent un an la pièce a été créée
en 1981 par par jean poiret ah
j'oubliais et un truc attention c'est
prêt vous n'échapperez à rien alors
c'est une pièce sur l'adultère en fait
mais y'a pas d'adultère dans la pièce et
c'est toujours comme toujours chez
poiret où j'ai fait monsieur est plus en
flagrant délit d'intention seulement
belle à la tension je fais le pitch oui
fait le pitch alors vous séduisez
barbara schulz vous l'inviter à prendre
un dernier verre à la maison et à ce
moment là votre épouse caroline silhol
qui soi-disant absente pour le week-end
de pâques
elle revient elle revient à cause d'une
grève des aiguilleurs
il revient il à sa part dans un délire
absolu
vous inventez au quart de tour à
mensonges et puis un mensonge on amène
un autre et ça se termine dans un délire
absolu intégral absolue training cents
la folie de poiret koala varzycois folie
sur elle de plus en plus de plus en plus
fous alors quand vous avez vu la pièce
la première fois ce monde la création
détient accompagnée par claude rich
frais et sur le trottoir en sortant vous
étiez mort de rire tous les deux et vous
avez dit j'aimerais bien jouer cette
pièce je lui dis je la jouerai je les
jouais et vous l'avez jonathan après ses
très jubilatoire de jouer ce personnage
non ce formidable parce qu'on peut on
peut se vautrer dans tout ce qu'on n'a
pas le droit de faire dans la vie c'est
à dire qu'on peut aller se vouent
retrait dans la lâcheté dans la mauvaise
foi soit son fils à ses mensonges élevé
au rang d'art suprême ques et le van
gogh du manceau
mais ça roule pour vous j'ai des bons
souvenirs de mensonges alors ça se passe
très bien donc c'est bourré se passe
très bien qui est pas le cas
malheureusement de tous les théâtres
compte massacre de monstres à difficile
à un peu difficile il faut se dépêcher
en plus parce que c'est seulement
jusqu'au 31 décembre oui ça quoi qu'il
arrive c'est fini après y'a pas de
tourner il faut bien dire aux gens ne
l'aurais fait avant d aller faire a été
fait
un an après c'est la reprise de l'école
des femmes de molière chez créée à
avignon cet été
ah ouais mais ça nous donnera l'occasion
de vos invités alors mais avec qui je
suis encore quelques petits trucs de
votre enfant ce qu'on n'a pas bien c'est
vrai à un des bonnes choses la halle à
rêver bon bah écoutez d'accord et voilà
donc je vous conseille moi je les ai vu
la pièce c'est vrai je m'en viens c'est
ce qu'on peut dire du boulevard sous
acide ans et re-non sein c'est très
surréaliste un petit peu oui oui c'est
formidable seraient incinérés le var je
veux bien qu'on appelle ça les
boulevards mais si tu est vraiment élevé
au rang d'art sur et ceni boulevard
comme feydeau et du boulevard way
jeunesse pâques
on a parlé de choses un petit peu plus
sérieuse oui dans son article du point
la semaine dernière bernard henri lévy
rapporté une discussion qu'il avait eu
avec des amis new-yorkais pour savoir ce
qu'il faudrait faire à l'emplacement du
world trade center enfin des tours
jumelles bernard henri lévy sont pas le
théâtre qui va total des deux ânes à
partir d'ogm on peut signaler parce que
la table une fois de plus c'est
lamentable c'est de la bêtise il ya
quelques rares lamentable mais un petit
mot pour ma première très gentil mais
ici lamentable j'ai envoyé un petit mot
alors donc d'abord il évident sa
dernière chronique du point rapporté une
discussion qu'il avait avec des amis
new-yorkais pour savoir ce qu'il
faudrait faire à l'endroit où étaient
les tours jumelles du world trade center
est-ce qu'il faut laisser le lieu vide
ce qu'il réussit une ruine comme il ya
un sarajevo la bibliothèque incendiée de
sarajevo hiroshima
il ya deux écoles peut-être faut-il
laisser une trace d'une quelque chose ne
s'est pas un morceau de ferraille qui
serait symboliserait cette chose qui a
eu lieu qui est terrible je crois
surtout qu'il faut qu'il faut
reconstruire la vie là dessus et je
crois que la plupart partisans d'un parc
d'un musée d'un mémorial où pensez que
c'est mieux de reconstruire quelque
chose qui t'avait crois que
malheureusement la fao
malheureusement ou heureusement le
mémorial de musées idée dans la tête de
chacun d'entre nous ouais je crois qu'on
peut on n'oubliera jamais cette image là
donc est ce que bon ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut oublier il n'est pas question
d'oublier
je me demande si quand même la meilleure
arme contre ce terrorisme qui terrorisme
ça veut aussi dire terreur est ce que
parce que l'acte erreur serait de
supprimer nos vies et la manière nous
vivons peut-être faudrait-il au
contraire faire reconnaître la vie d'une
manière encore plus puissante mais
peut-être la vie vit pas forcément le
symbole de l'économie ou du fric
quelque chose d'autre oui peut-être
c'est ça qu'il faut faire non moi le
temps
sylviane
on parlera pas assez bien pour les les
gens qui veulent absolument reconstruire
les tours à l'identique on peut
peut-être la femme en sous sol pour des
raisons de sécurité alors pierre arditi
vous réagissez comme ans à cette idée
qui se développe en france depuis
quelques temps qui consiste à dire que
ce qui s'est passé il ya un mois cette
semaine c'est bien entendu effroyable
mais que l'embargo américain affirmant
sur l'irak a déjà fait des centaines de
milliers de morts que ce sont eux les
américains qui ont inventé ben laden
pour virer les les russes d'afghanistan
qu'ils ont défendu israël au mépris des
droits de l'homme souvent au delà et de
la justice est ce que pour vous cette
attitude qu'ils développent en france
actuellement cinéma titude raisonnable
ou munich oise c'est vrai que l'amérique
armes et les talibans pour [ __ ] sur la
gueule des russes c'est clair bon
maintenant les talibans on se retourne
contre eux qu'on le veuille ou non
quoi qu'il ait pu faire les américains
c'est tout de même cette image n'est pas
acceptable je veux dire que cette cet
acte là je suis absolument désolé je
peux pas je peux pas l'accepter même si
je peux comprendre qu'un certain nombre
de choses ne sont pas résolus dans le
monde et qu'une partie de ces choses
sont de la responsabilité aussi de
l'amérique mais pas seulement
mais pas seulement il ya aussi les
responsabilités deux principaux
protagonistes est aussi responsabilité
d'un certain nombre d'états qui sont des
états confessionnels comme israël et
jacques nous avons nous la chance de
vivre dans un état dans une république
démocratique laïque et on a fait la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
c'est extrêmement différents je ne
dirais pas comme monsieur berlusconi qui
n'aura pas qu'ils ne ratent pas une
équipe vraiment les aligne les unes
derrière les autres les conneries que
nous serions forcément supérieur nous
aux autres bien sûr que nous sommes
simplement différent alors cette
différence de nous permettre d'accepter
la différence de l'autre sauf si l'autre
emploie des moyens qui n'acceptent plus
notre propre différence la démocratie ne
peut tolérer que ce qui la tolèrent et
là on a largement franchi les bornes
alors
non rien ne peut excuser ce qui s'est
passé à new york le 11 septembre rien
même si toute une série de choses
restent à régler et nous sommes bien
d'accord là dessus je suis moi par
exemple je suis juif je ne supporterais
pas compte qu'on liquide l'état d'israël
mais je ne supporte pas non plus l'état
de délabrement de dénuement et d'errance
dans laquelle se trouve aujourd'hui le
peuple palestinien voilà j'ai toujours
en mémoire aux idées que pensez vous de
cette idée de larguer en même temps sur
l'afghanistan des bombes pour tuer les
talibans et des vivres pour nourrir les
autres
si vous voulez mais ce que j'en ai pas
au summum de la compagnie on est au
summum de leur on est au summum delà du
ridicule si on peut employer un mot
aussi dérisoire pour quelque chose
d'aussi tragiques un à la fois on
balance des bombes sur des choses qu'il
faut probablement je le dis très
honnêtement détruire moi j'ai vu un
reportage est pas très longtemps sur m6
sur les talibans et sur ce que font les
talibans en afghanistan
c'est proprement indéfendable on ne
parle pas que des femmes d'ailleurs
quand les gens passent dans les stades
avec des fouets pour interdire aux
spectateurs de rire de sourire et qu'on
arrête le match pour exécuter des gens
sur la pelouse y joue au football nom de
honnêtement on peut blaguer défendre ça
c'est indéfendable
en même temps bien sûr qu'il faut
détruire ça peut-être aujourd'hui on en
est avec des bombes
il faudra peut-être s'arranger pour
détruire par d'autres moyens en même
temps elle avait un je ne sais pas je
balance est une bombe à droite et puis
un collègue que livre unitaire à gauche
et on sait pas quoi dire quand on est
quand même dans un
c'est la première fois où il ya un petit
souci d'humanité pendant un bombardement
aussi donc oui ça va aussi un côté
positif même si l'image ne change ou et
c'est vraiment du bombardement de leurs
actes et pas eu toutes ces questions je
suis ton on aurait peut-être pu balancer
des unes des colis de vivres
humanitaires un peu avant de balancer
les bombes
c'est à dire il ya quelques mois où on
n'est pas obligé d'attendre qu'il y ait
des régions comme est là pour aider des
peuples qui n'ont rien on peut faire ça
bon
on a beaucoup on a beaucoup parlé ici de
la taxe la taxe tobin qui consiste à
prélever un petit pourcentage sur les
flux monétaires internationaux personne
évidemment a voulu faire un texto been
même l'inventeur tobin ne veut plus en
entendre parler
finalement faute de payer la taxe tobin
l'occident va peut-être est obligé de
payer la taxe ben laden d'une certaine
façon ce sera plus cher oui c'est très
étonnant cette histoire de taxe tobin
parce qu'évidemment bon le raisonnement
immédiate convient pas évidement un
sursis sur ses énormes masses d'argent
on prend une toute petite partie 0,00 je
sais pas quoi et puis on aide le monde à
vivre moins mal ça semble l'évidence
même bien il ya une levée de boucliers
bouclier contre ça qui est absolument
consternants alors peut-être c'est pas
le bon moyen moi j'ai rien je suis pas
un économiste mais on se dit quand même
que je prends prenons une toute petite
partie uniquement ces mêmes langues
avoir annoncé même pas d'argent qui
appartient à quelqu'un c'est que c'est
que dalle
voilà il ya même ça s'ils sont pas
physiques visiblement un impensable à
bouger c'est un peu désespérant comme un
challenger un cauchemar puisque on parle
beaucoup de ces valeurs occidentales
sa part est il supérieur aux autres
biens peut-être faudrait-il se poser un
certain nombre de questions sur ses
valeurs et en tout cas si l'on se posait
la question sur ses valeurs au moins sur
leur respect et sur leur sens et
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on perd un peu
la notion du sens et du fonds pour de la
forme et pour du bruit du bruit de la
fureur qui ne signifie rien comme disait
shakespeare ce bruit cette fureur me
font peur